le résultat des travaux de l'artiste
belge est désormais visibles dans la
galerie base de l'ancien bâtiment
industriel
oui cela mûrisse est exposé dans toute
l'europe sont arrêtés à la mesure de la
démesure des bâtiments qu'il investit
les grands mobile qui l'a mise en place
ici viennent s'inscrire dans la
dimension des grandes portes qui
originellement ouvrait le bâtiment aux
quatre vents puisque ce sont d'anciennes
tenri donc il a vraiment regarder le
lieu il a vraiment analyser les matières
les couleurs les textures les volumes la
hauteur la largeur et il a produit des
volumes qui sont en discussion avec avec
cette spécificité
dans la galerie yachts des tanneries
toute autre ambiance la commissaire de
l'exposition les abysses mute a fait
appel à neuf jeunes artistes
ici il est question de visibilité et
d'utopie elle s'appuie ça c'est son
parti pris à elle sur un texte qui
s'appelle justement l'éternité par les à
ce qui a été écrit par auguste blanqui
qui est une des figures de la pensée
révolutionnaire du 19e siècle et qui en
prison alors qu'il ne voyait pas le ciel
se met à écrire un livre et de
cosmologie qui explique en gros selon
lui comment l'organisation des mondes
s'opère et se fait
on peut penser à ces images de
manifestations où on voit aussi des jets
d'eau qui sont utilisés pour mettre à
distance les publics
et il ya quelque chose qui renvoie au
mythe de sisyphe à la nécessité de tout
repenser rejouer constamment et d'être
dans ce rapport de force et de tension
nécessaire pour créer des équilibres
plus de 5000 visiteurs ont découvert le
centre des tanneries depuis son
ouverture il ya moins d'un an dont des
scolaires comme ces étudiants en classes
prépa d'art de bourges